[Musik]
Trainingslager der letzten Generation in
Berlin es stand unter dem Motto wir
befinden uns auf der Autobahn Richtung
klimahalle und wir haben den Fuß auf dem
Gas nach einer vierstündigen Erklärung
zum künstlicher beigeführten Ende der
Menschheit drängten sich erste Fragen
auf ich bin ja so ein bisschen
enttäuscht weil ich dachte das
Trainingscamp ist auf Bali das haben wir
in letzter Zeit häufiger aber
tatsächlich ist es kein Ort der jetzt
groß mit der letzten Generation eine
Verbindung hat ja jetzt wollen wir alle
wissen
genau wollten wir einmal eine kleine
Übung starten und zwar der ist aktives
Zuhören ich habe bisher keine Erfahrung
gemacht mit aktivistischen Blockaden
genau habe jetzt überlegt mich zu
radikalisieren und weil wir diesen
Training heute teilzunehmen
genau hab Angst dass es kalt ist und das
ist so meine Hoffnung dass ich
irgendwann Flashmob artig ganz viele
Leute dazu setzen vielen Dank fürs
Zuhören ich habe mich sehr verstanden
gefühlt von dir also ich habe jetzt
Sorgen weil ich jetzt mir jetzt auch
klar wird ihr meint es ernst
dass ich dann so als Loser dastehe und
dass ich dann nicht
ja so der Loser irgendwie bin auch in
der Sendung im ZDF und alle lachen
ja und was ich mir wünsche ist
Weltfrieden gesunde Umwelt
und die Playstation 5
und weiter ging es mit der lebensechten
Simulation einer Straßenblockade im
Berufsverkehr
wow
aber auch verschiedenste Formen der
Entsorgung von Aktivisten wollen erprobt
sein aktuell sehr beliebt das Päckchen
für die Polizei am
angenehmstenale Alternative zum
Autofahren
perspektivisch gesehen Perspektive
der schlaffe
wieder wollten wir ankleben üben
allerdings im Park schwierig und die
nächste Straße war weit weg
eine Bank wäre gut weil wenn man das
nicht mehr los kommt dann kann man sich
wenigstens hinsetzen dann wurde es
wirklich Hardcore sich anschreien lassen
von Autofahrern das muss auch geübt sein
und ganz wichtig bei dieser Übung ist
wenn man sich unwohl fühlt dann machen
wir Realität also wenn die Übung dabei
sage ich das an und dann machen wir
einmal Realität und dann ist alles
wieder normal wenn es zu viel wird wenn
es zu viel wird oder wenn es vorbei ist
okay
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in Scheiße reingefasst
diese Realität also wirklich am nächsten
Tag nun wurde es ernst ein paar letzte
Bedenken aber ich bin ja auch hier um
Tipps zu geben und das nicht alle einen
scheiße finden
aber könnte man den Autofahrer nicht als
Unterhaltung so ein bisschen jonglativ
bieten wenigstens
[Musik]
also mit drei brennenden Erdkugeln oder
ich habe mir den Stühlchen mitgebracht
ein bisschen bequemer ich will doch dass
es uns allen gut geht ich will ja auch
das ist alles ein bisschen
mainstreamiger wird wenn die Leute sehen
hier gibt's Nüsschen machen mit
ähm
ach so jetzt könnt ihr meine Nüsse nicht
essen weil die Hände alle angeklebt sind
wie viele Autofahrer im Berufsverkehr
konnten
nicht darum die Leute im Berufsverkehr
zu überzeugen wir verstehen ja dass die
sauer sind gar nicht weiterfahren
ehrlich das ist besser für Umwelt guck
mal wie viel Auto steht hier jetzt im
Motor läuft das ist noch schlimmer für
umweltig
ich habe kein Hunger Minuten später
waren keine Autos mehr da nur noch ein
paar Akademiker Demonstranten aus
Baden-Württemberg
da waren sie wieder das Päckchen und der
nasse Schlafsack und auch ich nahm all
meinen Mut zusammen okay
okay
ich habe mich dann was reinquatschen das
war schlechter Umgang tut mir leid ja
schön war's und damit zurück in die
Realität also wenn man mich lässt
so Aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische endcard
von Oliver Welke und der heute-show
leider ist das Video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den Kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres Video
anschauen vielen Dank so müsste jetzt
für immer reichen